[Música]
la policía brasileña dijo que el
principal sospechoso confesó el
asesinato del periodista británico tom
phillips y el indigenista bruno pereyra
el hombre habría llevado a las
autoridades hasta el lugar donde los
cuerpos fueron
desenterrados filis y pereira habían
desaparecido en el amazonas el pasado 5
de junio todo esto que se está dando en
brásil por ello nosotros vamos directo a
sao paulo y conectamos con nuestra
corresponsal valeria saccone valeria la
salud o muy buena mañana de jueves que
es lo más reciente que se sabe en esta
investigación tras los cuerpos hallados
en el amazonas
hoy esta noche deberían llegar
brasilia los cuerpos de los
desaparecidos para realizar unos
exámenes y para confirmar su identidad
sabemos que va a durar una semana porque
son exámenes de adn y en cuanto a tu
pregunta de la
investigación hay muchos puntos oscuros
en esta historia primero porque ellos
los dos sospechosos no confesaron un
primer momento de haber participado en
el asesinato sólo en el desaparecimiento
de los cuerpos ahora la policía está
diciendo que amar a toda costa ha
confesado pero hay que recordar que su
hermana ha acusado a la policía de
haberle torturado y ayer el jefe de la
policía dijo claramente que él había
confesado de forma espontánea además hay
otra historia que no se ha contado bien
el alcalde de talaia don ortzi estaba en
casa del marido dacosta el día en que
fue
realizada su prisión él fue
entrevistado en directo por el principal
canal de televisión de brasil y no vas a
explicar por qué estaba en casa del
principal iniciado en el que en aquel
momento y ahora con casa de las personas
que confesó
claro valeria le preguntó cuáles son
entonces los motivos que pudieron llevar
al asesinato de estas dos personas que
estaban desaparecidas de hace ya 11 días
todavía no está claro lo la principal
razón es que bruno pereyra estaba
intentando desmantelar una red de
pescadores furtivos de espiral y un
pescado protegido hay que decir que no
era una pesca a material era una pesca
realizada con barcos enorme de grandes
dimensiones que provocan grandes
consecuencias medioambientales en la
región pero también hay que recordar que
generan todos los empleados de la zona
de la fundación del indio es decir la el
órgano del estado que debería velar por
los indígenas están viviendo en
condiciones muy precarias
desde la llegada al gobierno del actual
presidente ya ir bolsonaro el propio
bruno que era había dejado la funai y
estaba colaborando con la asociación de
indígenas del valle de javarí y en los
empleados de la funai ha organizado en
una asociación independiente han
denunciado en un comunicado que la
situación de todas
las personas que trabajan en esta región
es muy precaria que reciben ataques y
amenazas de todo tipo y el propio bruno
en un audio que se conoció pocos días
antes de que encontrarse en su cuerpo
decía que disparaban concretamente
contra ellos entonces es una situación
que lamentablemente no es una regla